il en avait assez du bleu et du rose il
voulait faire quelque chose de neuf qui
fasse du bruit picasso a mis un an pour
réaliser les demoiselles d'avignon
prêté par le musée d'art moderne de new
york le tableau est à paris depuis
quelques jours au musée picasso bien sûr
le plus étonnant c'est qu'autour de
l'oeuvre plusieurs centaines d'études de
dessins et d'esquissés raconte la
jeunesse du tableau reportage de pierre
champetier et de gilbert usant surprise
les premiers pas sont académique picasso
fait ses gammes griffonne des bonshommes
inlassablement il veut se mesurer aux
bains turcs que d'un gros baigneuse de
sézanne il travaille retravaille les
formes classiques on reconnaît le spina
rios les cariatides l'esclave de
michel-ange voici la première
composition d'ensemble à elle compte
sept personnages c'est une scène de
bordel celui de la rue d'avignon à
barcelone cinq femmes s'exhibe devant
deux hommes l'un des tamarins avec cole
et pompon attablé devant un peu ron et
quelques tranches de pastèque symbole
sexuel évident il se roule une cigarette
en attendant son tour
le personnage est falot il disparaîtra
l'autre excite picasso lui-même est un
étudiant en médecine un livre sous le
bras il tire le rideau comme pour
effacer la scène c'est le savoir opposés
aux plaisirs et kasso lumea crâne dans
la main comme dans une vanité un animal
est pendu à ses basques c'est fric à la
chienne de l'atelier elle vient d'avoir
ses petits elle dort au pied de picasso
voici encore un pot de fleurs un cruchon
à lustres tout cela sans l'anecdote
picasso simplifie regardez ce qui arrive
aux carabins l'épaule devient fin et hop
le voici changer enfin exit ces
messieurs les dames s'adresse
directement à nous l'impact est plus
fort pour les présenter pirouettes et
valse hésitation assis debout lever les
bras tourné la tête encore picasso fait
subir à ses victimes toutes les
contorsions on entend craquer les
vertèbres
on voit la boue qui ce temps le nez qui
s'allonge ce fameux nez en cas de bris
les coudes et les genoux qui perce
c'est une explosion de l'intérieur une
métamorphose
ces deux mois celle de vienne cocotte de
papier le tableau fit un beau tapage
c'est une oeuvre charnière une sorte de
pivot avec une partie gauche qui
participe encore du monde classique et à
droite prenant le relais quelque chose
de nouveau
d'inconnus les respectueuse de la rue
d'avignon sont aujourd'hui entourée des
plus grandes marques de respect on dit
que leur voyage à paris a été assuré 50
millions de dollars